BOOKS BE BANNED.
ONE PROBLEM HERE, THE BOOKS
AREN'T EVEN IN THE LIBRARY.
NICK WATT IS OUT FRONT.
>> Reporter: FIVE YEARS AGO THIS
WAS ANOINTED THE BEST SMALL
LIBRARY IN AMERICA.
TODAY THE TRUSTIES ARE FACING A
RECALL.
>> WHAT I HATE TO SEE IS MY
COMMUNITY TORN APART LIKE THIS.
>> Reporter: THE DIRECTOR JUST
RESIGNED.
DO YOU FEEL YOU'VE GIVEN IN?
THAT YOU'VE BEEN DEFEATED HERE?
>> PART OF ME DOES, YES.
BUT THEY START SHOWING UP AT
YOUR HOUSE GUNS ON THEIR HIPS
AND BIBLE TRACKS IN THEIR HANDS.
>> Reporter: ACTIVISTS DEMANDING
THE LIBRARY BAN MORE THAN 400
BOOKS.
>> EVEN IF WE DO NOTHING TO YOU
EVENTUALLY IF YOU DON'T REPENT
OF HAVING TO HAVE OUR CHILDREN
WITH PORNOGRAPHY, THAT'S UP TO
GOD.
>> THINGS NEED TO CHANGE --
>> Reporter: ARE ANY OF THOSE
BOOKS IN THE LIBRARY?
>> NOT A SINGLE ONE.
>> Reporter: STILL THIS LITTLE
LIBRARY MIGHT NOT SURVIVE.
>> OUR INSURER HAS DECIDED TO
NOT RENEW FOR WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING ARE INCREASED RISK
EXPOSURES.
WE CAN'T OPERATE WITHOUT
INSURANCE.
>> Reporter: WE'VE BUMPED INTO
ONE OF THE PEOPLE -- SHE REFUSED
FOOTALK TO US.
IN FACT, EVERYONE ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE ARGUMENT WE REACHED
OUT TO REFUSED TO TALK TO US,
BUT ONE OF THEM DID COMPLAIN
THEIR MOTIVATION AT A LIBRARY
MEETING.
THEY ARE NOW HERE BECAUSE SO
MANY PEOPLE WERE SHOWING UP TO
THE MEETINGS, SO MANY WERE ARMED
THEY MOVED THE LIBRARY BOARD
MEETINGS TO A BIGGER BUILDING
THAT IS ALSO RIGHT NEXT TO THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
HERE IS THAT THAT ONE WOMAN'S
MOTIVATION.
>> MY JOB IS TO PROTECT OUR KIDS
FROM SEXUAL DEVIANCE, WHO WILL
BE DRAWN TO OUR LIBRARY IF
INAPPROPRIATE SEXUAL MATERIALS
IS ON OUR SHELVES AND USING OUR
KIDS AS PREY.
>> Reporter: THIS WEEK BE SHOWED
UP WITH CAMERAS TO A BOARD
MEETING.
>> IT WAS WONDERFUL TO NOT BE,
LIKE, ATTACKED.
>> Reporter: AND THE WOULD-BE
BOOK BANNERS DID NOT.
>> SO WHAT IS GOING ON, NICK, IS
THERE IS A GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE MOVING INTO THE AREA
WHO ARE -- THEY HAVE THE INTENT
OF TURNING THIS INTO WHAT THEY
CALL THE AMERICAN REDOUBT.
>> Reporter: CONTINUED BACK IN
2011 BY A CHRISTIAN
REVIVALALIST, THE AMERICAN
DOUBT, A REFUGE FOR
SELF-DESCRIBED GOD FEARING
LIBERTY LOVING PATRIOTS.
THE STORE OWNED BY A PASTOR WHO
MOVED UP FROM CALIFORNIA, HERE'S
HOW HE DESCRIBED IT BACK IN
2015.
>> IF WE WILL PUT HIM FIRST
BLESED WILL BE THE REDOUBT.
BY GOD'S GRACE WE TRUST THAT THE
REDOUBT WE WON'T SEE THE HOMO
SEXUALITY AND RAMPANT LESBIANISM
WE SEE IN CALIFORNIA.
>> Reporter: SOME REALERS CATER
TO THEM.
ONE HAS THIS AD ON THEIR
WEBSITE.
>> IN THE DAYS OF OLD, MEN WOULD
NEED AND WOMEN WOULD NURTURE.
>> Reporter: THEY WERE
HEADQUARTERED IN THIS PART OF
IDAHO AND THEY HAD A SIMILAR
PLAN BUT FOR A WHITES-ONLY
HOMELAND UP HERE.
MANY LOCALS FOUGHT AGAINST THAT.
TODAY MANY LOCALS ARE FIGHTING
AGAINST THE REDOUBTERS AND THE
BOOK BANNERS.
>> THEY'VE BEEN GOING TO LIBRARY
BOARD MEETINGS AND YELLING AND
SCREAMING AT PEOPLE.
AND WE'RE HERE BEING VERY QUIET
AND VERY POLITE.
WE'RE HAVING A READ-IN SUPPORT
OF THE LIBRARY.
>> Reporter: THE RESISTANCE HERE
IS A COALITION OF LIBERALS AND
CONSERVATIVES.
THIS IS A PRETTY CONSERVATIVE
CHRISTIAN COMMUNITY.
>> VERY SO.
>> Reporter: AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
HERE OAT VOTED FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
>> VERY MUCH SO.
>> Reporter: EVEN MORE VOTED FOR
HIM IN 2020 BUT --
>> THIS GOES BEYOND ANY
CONSERVATISM AND INTO ALMOST
NAZISM WHERE THEY'RE TRYING TO
FORCE THEIR OWN IDEAS AND THEIR
OWN RELIGIOUS CONCEPTS ON
EVERYBODY ELSE.
THAT'S NOT AMERICA.
>> Reporter: WE SPOKE TO THE
FORMER MAYOR, YOU KNOW, WHO
VOTED FOR TRUMP, AND HE'S ON THE
SAME SIDE AS LIBERAL PEOPLE
HERE.
>> WELL, OF COURSE.
YEAH.
WE'RE NEIGHBORS.
>> Reporter: THE COWBOYS ILWOMAN
VAL THOMPSON'S FAMILY HAS BEEN
HERE FIVE GENERATIONS.
>> ONE OF MY FRIENDS HAD SOMEONE
TELL HIM THE OTHER DAY THAT THE
AMERICAN REDOUBT IS HERE AND IT
MIGHT BE TIME TO EXIT.
>> Reporter: THERE ARE
POLITICIANS LIKE THIS RUNNING.
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT REALLY
RAUNCHY STUFF IN THESE BOOKS FOR
7-YEAR-OLDS.
YOU NEED A GOOD SHERIFF AND
THREE COUNTY COMMISSIONERS.
>> Reporter: THERE ARE CLAIMS
CRITICAL RACE THEORY IS BEING
TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS AND --
>> WE HAD ONE MOM COME IN AND
SAY THIS HAS BLACK LIVES MATTER
THEMES.
>> Reporter: DID IT?
>> IT WAS A FAIRY TALE BY
CHRIS -- SO IT PROBABLY HAS
PEOPLE OF COLOR IN THAT BOOK.
>> Reporter: IN THAT LIST I SAW
WHO WAS FREDERICK DOUGLAS.
>> RIGHT.
>> Reporter: WHY IS THAT AN
ISSUE?
>> WELL, I HAVEN'T READ "WHO WAS
FREDERICK DOUGLAS," BUT I'M
ASSUMING THAT THERE WAS
SOMETHING IN IT THAT WAS
OFFENSIVE OR MADE SOMEBODY FEEL
GUILTY FOR BEING WHITE.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
>> Reporter: AS I'VE SAID IT'S
NOT IN THE LIBRARY, NEITHER IS
"GENDER QUEER."
BUT --?
>> THE CONFLICT IS I CANNOT SAY
WE'LL GET THEM BECAUSE WE'RE A
LIBRARY.
IF THE PUBLIC COMES AND REQUESTS
THOSE BOOKS, WE'LL GET THOSE
BOOKS.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO.
>> Reporter: THEY SAY THEY ARE
NOT CENSORS AND THIS LIBRARY
MUST SERVE EVERYONE.
>> NICK, AS YOU NOTED THERE
NOBODY FROM THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE ARGUMENT WANTED TO SPEAK
WITH YOU.
HOW ARE THEY REACTING NOW TO ALL
THIS ATTENTION?
>> Reporter: WELL, ERICA, JUST
THIS MORNING THE WOMAN WHO YOU
JUST SAW IN THAT REPORT HERE IN
THE LIBRARY TAKING OUT MORE
BOOKS TO SEE IF THEY SHOULD BE
BANNED SHE WROTE A LETTER TO A
BUNCH OF LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND PROSECUTORS, EVEN TO THE
STATE ATTORNEY GENERAL NOTING
THIS IS NO LONGER JUST A LOCAL
STORY, THIS IS NATIONAL.
AND SHE IS ACCUSING THE LIBRARY
DIRECTOR AND THE LIBRARY
SUPPORTERS OF TRYING TO SILENCE
THEM, IGNORING THEM AND LYING TO
THE PRESS AND ALSO ALLEGING
THERE'S ALSO NOW SOME KIND OF
COZY RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
SUPPORTERS OF THE LIBRARY AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
SO SHE IS NOW ASKING THAT AN
OUTSIDE BODY COMES IN HERE TO
INVESTIGATE WH